hace un mes más o menos recibe una
invitación de un buen amigo mi tocayo
alejandro espinoza
a vivir una experiencia autor naturaleza
la invitación fue por whatsapp y les
pongo cómo fue que había tocado cómo
anda es que hacia el río bravo y le
pongo halo y podía nos fuimos salimos de
monterrey bien temprano
y llegamos a la base que está al norte
de coahuila nos hicimos un comido una
carne asada de esas para dormir parado y
el día siguiente cruzamos el río bravo
llegamos a texas a donde está el take
the national park y nos topamos con unos
expertos en el autor y en en rafting y
ahí me enteré una media hora antes a lo
que íbamos resulta que vamos a hacer
canotaje
en el río bravo yo jamás me hubiera
imaginado que puedes andar en el agua
entre méxico estados unidos me imaginaba
la migra conoces mike pero si nos iban a
deportar pero resulta que no que es
legal y que hay empresas que se dedican
a eso muy bonito y la verdad es una
experiencia muy recomendable
les quería compartir
y lo que sentía ya lo que lo que pensé
te pones nos explican te pones a la vida
se empieza a borrar tus cosas tu comida
tu tienda de campaña tu sleeping bags
hasta el baño portátil también te sale a
canadá te dan a ciertas indicaciones y
estamos ya en el río bravo y te pones a
remar
de repente había rápidos
te explicaba por aquí pero ya no te
caigas el agua está muy fría en rápido
es muy leve pero empezaba a fluir la
adrenalina
pero había había partes en el río en el
agua estaba muy quieta solamente
escuchaba el sonido del aire entrando y
viajando por el cañón de santa elena
miraba la parte gméxico mira la parte
eeuu escuchar los pájaros ni siquiera
llevamos hablando entre nosotros
y creo que todos sigamos pensando lo
mismo y contemplando pues los paisajes
del hermoso lugar lo que yo pensé era no
somos nada
y me refiero estás en la ciudad vuelto
loco estresado por llegar a la siguiente
junta
descansado el tráfico preguntando por la
contraseña del wifi que después de la
pregunta del hola cómo estás la pregunta
inmediata que sigue es cómo me conecto
y suena raro pero pasa en una ciudad tan
grande como acá
con mucha concentración de gente estamos
solos y cuando estás en un lugar como el
que estábamos que era un desierto donde
hay muy poca gente estás en contacto con
la naturaleza esas relaciones son más
auténticas son más reales y pues como no
buscan en un casino se ven y cuando se
ven hay que aprovechar la plática y se
disfruta la compañía ese ruta una buena
comida
y ahí entra otro tema en un lugar así
cualquier comida te sabe a gloria y
cualquier cualquier comodidad es un lujo
a qué me refiero en este viaje que
hicimos no era como que tenemos que
casar y conseguir la comida pero sí
cargarla cargar el baño portátil
que no se echará a perder la comida
mantenerla cocinarla obviamente
guardarla limpiarla y seguir remando
seguir remando
otras cuatro horas seguidas llegar poner
la tienda de campaña de dos por uno en
mi caso era de tres por tres en sleeping
bags llegas todo destrozado derramar
cuatro horas adolorido sólo a unas
piernas en la espalda
de todos lados pero estás en medio del
cañón de santa elena empieza a arrollar
la brisa del sonido del agua de los
pájaros y esa cama resulta la mejor y
esa comida que estoy haciendo en el
fuego que tú perdiste te sabe a gloria y
lo mejor es que se comparte con familia
y con amigos
todos teníamos todos tenemos hambre
todos estábamos adoloridos algunos
tenían más frío que otros porque se
cayeron al agua y está bien fría y con
el aire entrando el cañón no te pega el
sol pues sí sí poder hipotermia pero
estamos ahí estamos alrededor de una
fogata compartiendo sentimientos
achaques y contemplando la naturaleza
y cuando volteas a ver la pared de 95
metros de altura en el cañón de santa
elena te das cuenta de lo insignificante
que somos como seres humanos
te das cuenta que no dependemos de la
madre naturaleza pero
ella no depende de nosotros que
dependemos mucho de la madre naturaleza
que de hecho les estorbamos que funciona
tan matemáticamente bien que es una
máquina perfecta y que al final le salen
sobrando nuestros likes
a veces puedo pensar que la solución
para el cambio climático es a más no
estar
no estará aquí dejé chingar la dejé
hacer las cosas qué pasaría si todos al
mismo tiempo en todo el mundo
no prende la luz no prende la tele no
salgas en el carro no vayas a la fábrica
no abra la tienda todos en el mundo al
mismo tiempo durante un mes con un día
tenemos creo que la madre naturaleza se
restablecería
todo esto que los prácticos se llevó a
cabo en una reserva natural
de 140.000 hectáreas es un área natural
protegida que ese es el legado de cemex
neicer hacia la conservación de la flora
y la fauna de este lugar
y allí donde estábamos a la orilla del
río entre el cañón de santa elena en la
fogata con la dinámica de compartir de
pasar los alimentos con esa misma
actividad y esa dinámica así es como se
descubre el fuego por esa misma razón
nuestros ancestros utilizaban el fuego
para iluminarse para protegerse de
depredadores para calentarse para
cocinar alimentos obviamente era tan
importante el fuego que había una
persona encargada de mantenerlo vivo de
que se movían de lugar de llevarlo de
viajar con él era el hogar portátil
siempre donde llegará el fuego era la
casa era el hogar
en donde hay un hogar hay familia hay
amigos hay personas afines a nosotros
que conjugan los mismos principios y los
mismos valores hogar proviene de hoguera
y eso y con ese mismo fuego con el que
estoy hablando que está desde las cuevas
hasta horita así se crea la sociedad
mexicana de parrilleros y como comunidad
que somos tenemos un propósito en común
cuál es nuestro propósito
genera lazos y unir a las personas
queremos que por medio de experiencias
memorables alrededor del fuego estar en
familia estar con los amigos
estaban la madre ada con una sonrisa
reír creemos que podemos generar más
empatía con los demás tener una mejor
sociedad dejar y tener un mundo mejor
un movimiento que trasciende se crea
atrás a raíz de un propósito es lo que
significa estar en comunión somos una
comunidad
y estamos alrededor del fuego es el
mismo fuego que sabe en el río estaban
las cavernas y hasta que ahora también
ha evolucionado la que emergió con esto
evoluciona la forma de viajar con él
ahora lo podemos puesto un encendedor
nos ha ayudado a construir puentes
rascacielos está en la comida de la casa
prender la estufa picando un botón es el
fuego ha evolucionado nos ha ayudado a
construir auditorios también
y allí con todo eso que les practicó me
quedó más que claro que también el
movimiento evoluciona no podemos
quedarnos estáticos
un movimiento que trasciende no se puede
quedar estático si nos quedamos
estáticos nos morimos
a qué me refiero yo he catalogado el
movimiento o la evolución de este
movimiento en cuatro etapas
ciertamente las etapas son diferentes en
todas otras zonas del mundo en otros
tiempos esto fue que me tocó vivir a mí
en el tema de la parrillada la etapa 1
me acuerdo en casa mis papás la carne
asada era el asador a cielo abierto los
ladrillos en esquina de las piedras
hasta un bote de basura partido a la
mitad y orientadas unos pellejos unas
flechas salchichera las que sabía una
salsa tatemada en guacamole
y listo no
la etapa 2 en la que hemos visto llegar
los asadores de eta para favorecer
amigos empieza a saber que un asador de
tapas utiliza la energía es una
convección lo traduces en un horno y
empezamos a hacer cortes gruesos empieza
el rival de pulgada 2 pulgadas 3
pulgadas hasta la pieza entera y
empiezan a cambiar los nombres el río
aire el cabo y el tomahawk y el port
vell y que al final es lo mismo pero
pues escucho más chido
etapa 3 no solamente es carne asada nos
damos cuenta que se pueden hacer pizzas
postres pasteles ensaladas frutas asadas
absolutamente todo no pulpo pescado
mariscos
la etapa 4
hemos visto es el tema del barbecue son
los ahumados porque utiliza el por un
mezquite hay infinidad de leña que te
permite diferentes aromas y empiezan los
ahumados las técnicas de cocción larga
para cocinar busquets del baby back
gripe charlie es una cultura que viene
eeuu y que ahorita es como sería la
etapa 4
seguramente van a venir más etapas
y todas todas están bien va a cambiar la
etapa conforme a la técnica de cocción a
tendencias en el mundo e ingredientes
pero creo que en todo en todo movimiento
evolutivo considero que es que hay que
recordar de dónde venimos
hace poco en el río bravo en el cañón de
santa elena
el estar tiene que cargar la comida
tienes que aprender tu propio fuego
tienes que cocinar limpiar recoger
guardar y seguir remando otras cuatro
horas para llegar al destino si no te
puedes no te puedes quedar sentado no te
puedes quedar estático ahí fue donde
donde me hizo clic
evolutivo también es volver pero por qué
no evolucionar no de una forma lineal
sino de una forma circular
volver a los orígenes la forma perfecta
de la naturaleza el círculo
hace 200 años en esta reserva natural
del carmen estaba llena de osos de
bisontes de borregos de pumas de
halcones de lobos
y por consecuente es consecuencia de
este mismo movimiento el ecosistema se
ha habido se ha visto mermado y
disminuido hasta desplazado igual que
muchos otros partes del mundo que no me
dejará mentir está por todos lados
yo estoy consciente de todo esto y por
eso estoy aquí parado con la
responsabilidad de hacer algo al
respecto todos los que somos parte de
este movimiento somos parte del problema
pero también todos somos parte de la
solución todos en esta comunidad podemos
aportar algo y encontrar el equilibrio
si queremos seguir echando lejos que no
se apague la lumbre de seguir haciendo
carne asada si queremos seguir
compartiendo momentos con la familia con
los amigos sonreír los 'stress tenemos
que tomar acción
entonces cuál es la etapa número 5 en
este movimiento alrededor del fuego
es la carne asada responsable
el 31 de agosto y 1º septiembre del año
pasado aquí en el hermoso municipio de
santiago nuevo león organizamos el grove
master que es el campeonato de para
llegar más grande de américa latina
esto es todo esto fue un minuto de aquí
en ese evento recibimos 28.000 personas
en dos días cocinamos y comimos 7.000
kilos de proteína de carne consumimos
3000 kilos de carbón y leña 100 mil
litros de agua y 90 toneladas de basura
y gracias al esfuerzo de mucha gente
involucrada de organizaciones de
empresas
de parrilleros y de voluntarios
y logramos hacerlo libres de emisiones
de co2
entonces si es posible hacer una carnita
asada
para 28.000 personas libre de emisiones
de co2 no será posible hacerlo en la
carnaza familiar en un domingo cuando
hay un juego fútbol cuando son 5 o 6
peleado nada más
yo no tengo la respuesta absoluta pero
sí estoy convencido que si primero
tomamos conciencia
si nos responsabilizamos entre todos
como comunidad que somos podemos
encontrar la solución
hoy el fuego que nos une está a nuestras
manos nos toca hacer conciencia y tomar
acciones para hacer una carne sea
responsable
[Aplausos]